because our conscious awareness is such
a fantastical mechanism that see the the
cosmos can't look at itself right it's
just stuff following the rules of
physics but here humans arise on this
huge probability platform that cycles
for for over 4 billion years and our
brains are at the top of that platform
and when we look out at the cosmos we
are the cosmos seeing itself for the
first time so it's a it's an amazing
thing is your consciousness looks back
at its own origins that creates what
spiritual teachers call non-dual Union
but it's a different kind of non-dual
Union not with sort of a psychic space
or the space of a religious tradition or
spiritual tradition it's a non-dual
union with the total emergence and
evolution of life yes and that's going
to be a different kind of non-dual union
that's that's broader I think because
it's all encompassing
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are at the transformative technology
conference an incredible gathering of
human beings we have the opportunity and
the great pleasure now of sitting down
with Bruce Damer thank you thank you for
coming on into our show yes so welcome
greatly appreciate it and I'm so excited
for this conversation
Bruce is a scientist who studies the
origin of life at UC Santa Cruz and I
love studying the origin of life as you
guys know and also about the current
state of life and where we're going in
the future so this is going to be I'm
super excited so I want to before we
jump in to the you know to where you're
kind of like currently really focused
and passionate about you know tell me
who the hell are you how did you even
get to who you are did I get here yeah
after four billion years finally I'm a
kid from Canada from British Columbia
and I was always dreaming my mind was
always going into the far future back
into the past and I used to walk in
nature all the time and I dreamed up
this stuff and then read about Albert
Einstein who did the same thing but he
wrote a bike around like a madman and so
that's how I thought all of science was
done so I just led my life through
thought experiments the imagination sort
of matrix and went through many lives
and I'm here I'm 56 and right on
schedule we came up with a potential
solution for how life began on earth
which was my dream when I was 14
oh man okay so I love where you took me
at the very beginning which was this
kind of this this young Bruce that just
experientially liked to learn through
was it mostly alone and with nature yeah
yeah yeah so that was the error of the
first generation of Star Trek
which I got into later later Captain
Kirk William Shatner beamed me out of my
Cray supercomputer in my computer Museum
and in my barn but I used to walk along
and see the sagebrush as little oak
trees and realized I could I was like a
commander and that I could create Majan
alexa Ville is Asians that were down
there and then I made them in my
imagination and I drew thousands of
photograph of drawings of illustrations
of these worlds so because you were all
bored in school right so I I just poured
it out in in these elaborate
civilizations I like drawing over years
and years yeah okay I have to say I have
fallen in love with with two words
recently the two words that make us that
make a field that I haven't even heard
that exists really yet it's Universal
Design a year ago or so my dreams all
came true like we came up with a model
for how life began its are these cycling
pools hot spring pools but at the same
time my other dream was how to give life
a path into the cosmos right because
earth is a womb but it's a tomb right we
got to burst out and that's the other
track that I've been working on yes they
both came into realization in the same
day and this two TEDx talks I get I did
parallel TEDx talks morning and evening
and then the publication of the
technical articles for how to expand
into space and how to figure out how we
began were published in the same day
into two different journals and so I was
walking up in skyline there's so much of
me and you yeah well I asked I asked the
field I asked the field how could this
all have come about in such a
miraculously co-joined perfectly timed
process and in my my ear came the voice
well it's your universe
is your universe so then I realized that
each of us walks along with this brain
case with neural connections that
actually out number the countable
particles in the cosmos right our brains
are deeply ramified matter that are
bigger than the cosmos in the at the
countable level and so when we walk
around we shape probability all around
us even though we're not aware of it
so our dreams become reality against all
odds and we are walking universes yeah
yeah I see it in your eye I'm so I so
want to ask you so many questions
there's so much to talk about I want to
stay where you were just that and then
we can talk about the origin of life and
the civilizational birthing from the
womb ok so where we were just that tell
us more about this this we are each in
our own universe I think that because
our conscious awareness is such a
fantastical mechanism that see the the
cosmos can't look at itself right it's
just stuff following the rules of
physics but here humans arise on this
huge probability platform that cycles
for over 4 billion years and our brains
are at the top of that platform and when
we look out at the cosmos we are the
cosmos seeing itself first time yes so
many you know serious gearhead
scientists actually have written about
this the cosmos became self-aware yes
because we are self-aware and we're made
of the cosmos yes and so what does that
really mean what does that really mean
it means that the cosmos itself is
imaged and comes into a reality of
different reality in your mind and in
your network than in any other right
because but you are such a large system
you have 13 trillion cells a hundred
trillion gut bacteria and 14 quadrillion
mitochondria that are spinning and
making energy so your system is immense
so compared to say the complexity of a
galaxy you totally outclassed
galaxy in terms of the complexity just
you walking along so as you walk along
the interconnected network of
probabilities that are constantly
working through your system and through
evolution through the biosphere is so
large that it's literally rendering a
reality in real-time click click click
click click which is a reality of the
cosmos itself and as we as scientists
start looking out in you know the Hubble
or the James Webb it's just coming up
where we'll actually see the ignition of
the cosmos and somebody like me whose
mind is back in the Hadean era rooting
for progeny and protocells to make it
through the cycles now we have a model
that's testing out in the field in
actual hot springs I'm rooting for them
my mind is back over four billion years
ago in their little proto cellular world
where they're not even able to divide
but they're going through cycles
combinatorial selection cycles and
they're lifting into the first cellular
life and this that birthing period where
I live a lot of the time now but my
consciousness is in them is in them and
it's cycling with them and it's it's
giving them the hopes and dreams we know
that that worked but if you put yourself
back 4.2 billion years ago there was no
guarantees that life would actually
emerge yeah lift it out of inanimate
matter you know so that was the cosmos
birthing a whole new layer through its
clockwork mechanisms you know it's why
probably why it came into existence so
it's a it's an amazing thing is your
consciousness looks back at its own
origins that creates what spiritual
teachers call non-dual Union but it's a
different kind of non-dual Union not
with sort of a psychic space or the
space of of a religious tradition or
spiritual tradition it's a non-dual
union with the total emergence and
evolution of life yes and that's going
to be a different kind of non-dual union
that's that's broader I think because
it's all-encompassing the origin of life
is a Nandu
Union and your conception of it so when
your mind opens to the largeness of the
cosmos it goes into the state of awe
when your mind looks down into cells and
how complex the machinery is but when
your mind goes back to see the trials
and tribulations of proto cellular life
coming in and you feel in your heart for
it that's a total Union that's total
Union that's totally Union could I also
say that when even when I look back just
even even a thousand ten thousand at the
birth of Agriculture when I look back
six million at the monkey to human
transition when I look back at the
dinosaurs 65 million and this is all
part of my heart this is part of my soul
this is part of the Union yes with life
it is beautifully said yeah yeah and
there's there's there's just this
there's something that just makes me or
does it makes me cry because 'men I've
been obsessing over the 100 billion
people that lived and died for us today
to build this beautiful world you live
in
yeah I've been obsessing about it so
much that I've been writing about it and
making she clips about it and I and I'm
really excited to take full take it to
the next level soon and I'm not known a
rush to take it to the next level either
because I want it to be I wanted to take
take time and do it the right way and
the the obsession of that has has drawn
the deepest amounts of empathy and great
gratitude out of my soul yeah yeah I
think you hit it it's empathy and
gratitude that's the really the sole way
we can connect with this and that when
we feel the gratitude and we also are
presented with the incredible chance
that we even exist because rocky worlds
don't hold their liquid water we now
know this Mars is an example I just came
back from the Mars 2020 landing site
meetings
or were down to three sites now and last
year I presented the case for where you
would find life on Mars based on a hot
spring origin and then the escape of
life down into the Martian rock because
the surface became uninhabitable it
became sterilizing and so Mars died
maybe even as life started there Venus
went straight to a hothouse situation
and the earth by some miracle held on to
liquid oceans for three and a half
billion years long enough for complex
life that's no guarantee we are a
blessed result of fortuitous chance that
is so extraordinary you know that that
for me is like the ultimate gratitude
and we make there may be no alien
civilizations within 50 parsecs of here
this place it made me nothing because as
Kepler looks at more EXO solar systems
we go oh my gosh we are so extraordinary
we are so rare and extraordinary and it
gives us like we may be alone
effectively and and in that case the
magnificence of what this is you know
and what each human being from Donald
Trump to the little baby they're all
extraordinary miracles of creation all
of them and if we look into our souls
the good news in the early 21st century
is we now know how humans boot up as an
operating system we know Trump trauma
you know we have internal family systems
we have you know basically brain scans
that show us how the brain works we have
tools like psychedelics like meditation
like everything here like muse and bio
beats I just came from there we have the
most incredible tools to help us heal so
we're not coming from parts are not
coming from trauma yeah so that we won't
self-immolate we won't destroy this this
world and destroy ourselves and we
finally got the boot codes for humans
just in time yeah yeah hey Justin would
you would you say that on the other side
of the
of the of the traumas that are kind of
their generational in many many many
ways that on the other side of that is
the unity that that in the yeah because
there was you were talking about the
incredible technologies that are here
and almost all the technologies that are
at the transformative technology
conference are about unity and in fact
Joe Hudson this morning we did that
about an hour and a half of basically
eye gazing between these strange people
yeah
Joe is so skillful we had him on the
show and he yeah he answered my I
usually ask a couple questions that of
the show and he he's the first person
that that ever so quickly I asked the
question what's the most beautiful thing
in the world and he was just like now
looking in the other's eyes right now
yeah yeah yeah and and and I do I I
learned about that maybe like four or so
years ago about the dish what looking
into someone's eyes for those long
periods of time there's no hate no hate
not a drop of hate and and and then the
then the the profound overwhelming sense
of love and connection and and then to
replicate that with other people and
then Joe was so grateful he does his
just assume he's and he's bringing it
into Business and Finance and hardcore
high-tech right so you know I look at
these people that are at the tops of
their games we had Kyle Kingsbury came
over and to do his podcast for on it
right this fantastic company that does
learned about fats and brain health and
everything
he's like WFC champion like two three
things and he's like the most
testosterone driven guy but he is so
much love coming he is so he's an avatar
for the decent beautiful human being
beautiful man and so is Joe Rogan and
and these are the toughest fighters in
our society so these are guys in WFC
they come in you know and look at what
they are look at their look at their
power look at their hearts and I told
Kyle Cao Kingsbury I said you are an
avatar for some of the greatest hope in
humanity you sitting here right there
and you know you could take my neck and
wring it right right now I mean you
there's so much power the most body
power but yeah they're totally
integrated beautiful humans and they're
the hope you know so they can face they
can face the traumatized power because
look at how powerful they are you know
yeah you know there's there's something
about the it it make it makes me it
makes me cry because Joe in many ways is
what what what I would say one of if not
the leading interviewer of our time yeah
and and and one who partakes in that
many conversations with that many
diverse leaders from around the world is
inevitably going to become a very
intelligent multidisciplinary mind and I
that's why I am also doing this that's
why you're doing this yeah and it's the
Golden Age of this work and you're in
the middle of it and yes and viewers and
each stewardship yeah and and I'm and
I'm I'm gonna propel that as best as I
can needs new public intellectuals from
all branches that are fearless
and a hag line is rebirthing the public
intellectual oh is it yeah well I just
met on the out just for your listeners
and viewers the kind of people that are
here so James Hinault so was walking in
and we talked and talked about another
powerful public intellectual with
digital rain and
the esalaam programs they're doing and
all the programs there everywhere there
is walking around here and you know
Silicon Valley and other places are
powering up the new public intellectual
and they're fearless and they're
fearless because they face your own
demons they've done medicine journeys
which would you know strip the paint off
of most of us so they faced they face
harsher fears then then you can and say
a boardroom or in a political office so
it's like what what phases them they
care about the future of this the human
Enterprise this experiment and they're
here
we're gonna make it I have no doubt
we've got the we've got the dream team
we've got the cohort yeah to do this
thing and I meet them all over the world
I'm traveling over the world talking
about how life began and here's a here's
a big one for you for a public
intellectual this is going to be as
powerful for the 2020s as relativity was
for the 1920s so Einstein his general
special relativity were proven by the
eclipse of 1919 when Mercury's light
actually of not Mercury it was a star
light was bent around the Sun and so he
was sponsored on a tour of America in
1921 with Charlie Chaplin and he became
the first scientific rock star because
his funny hair and Charlie Chaplin and
he didn't know what was going on but he
was good for the camera right so and
this is the beginning of media short
films film was booming the 1920s was the
most modernizing decade until the 60s in
the 20th century so you had the rise of
electronic training trading radio
consumerism women's lib it was
incredible decade new literature new
theater fascism rose the post kingship
world just exploded and what rolled that
from science was the theory of
relativity that there was no base
everything's relative to everything else
everything is changing
even time as is variant and I believe
that our origin of life model where
we're empirically showing that life
started from a community not an
individual is such a powerful change
it's a powerful role for the 2020s so we
were actually we believe we're going to
be able to show is that an individual
little pro to sell at the beginning is
too wobbly and doesn't have enough
molecular functions to do anything it
falls apart but in a clump in a sludge
in what's called the pro to note it is
this unit of selection so the roots of
the tree of life is not individuals it's
a community so our art we came from a
community complex in collaboration
that's a big change and so there was a
term coined by Herbert Spencer in the
19th century that survival of the
fittest
right we all know it and Charles Darwin
was sort of browbeaten to put it in the
third volume of his great book into the
Origin of Species and he didn't like it
he used natural selection so the
survival of the fittest came into the
the language and the culture as a very
Victorian term you know who were the
fittest the white Victorians you know
the brown people aren't etc and it was
used to justify death pogroms genocides
in the 20th century called social
Darwinism right we have the chance now
of rollin survival of the fittest out of
our lexicon out of our culture because
we started as a collaborative community
and our bodies or collaborative
communities our cities everything is a
collaborative community but the
isolation created by that term of I must
defend myself and win against all others
is destructive the separation the
stories of separation the fake news the
the panic right that's the crux point
that we're at but out of science out of
hard core reductionist science we'll
roll this realization like seeing the
Earth from space and Apollo eight review
effect an overview effect this little
sludge growing in the bottom of a dish
that's evolving and scientists you know
in lab coats pointing to it and said
this is a punitive way that life began
on earth and it's a community we started
from a community not an individual and
that'll pout that'll power its way into
the culture in a beautiful way and I'm
hoping it's the 2020s in honor of
Einstein's 1921 emergence yeah we first
started talking about Einstein in
Chaplin I was thinking about like what
would it look like to have a like just
hardcore a scientist with hardcore
entertainer you know on on stage playing
playing playing dancing having fun and
teaching and what would what would that
look like in this new age of media and
then I also as you were talking that's
what we're doing by the way
yeah I've been doing these shows with
DJs and dancers and one of the art we
created this with Android Jones
so Android Jones that our first show we
did it at lightning in a bottle on huge
screens and he was doing live painting
and then we did shows all last year and
the in the temp The Burning Man a
pyramid the playa alchemists last year
and what are you doing at the live shows
the painting what I do is literally we
set it up so there's fantastic music
written by DJ dissolve and as DJ
dissolve he's a DJ to dissolve al
santana and they do it and he plays live
violin to invoke what's coming and the
whole place goes that we did this at the
sand saturday nights and show last year
we were we did this there so then comes
in that show Samantha came and gave the
invocation and then Jasmine came was
fantastic dancer so she danced the
energies up and then I then the album
goes quiet and then there's a
thunderclap and I walk out and I'm
wearing my my wizard whatever I'm doing
and I come out I'm lit beautifully and
then the v-j starts to do the visuals
and then I look at the audience and ice
RDM and the story is range from where we
came from to where we're going yeah and
they're all they're all tuned to a 23
year old kind of millennial audience but
it generally works for everyone yeah in
the festival scene or at Burning Man
where there's a lot of distractions to
hold that audience so that I've been
doing that now for two years as a show
yeah sweet so any of your your viewers
wanted to have a performance and that's
an example what is the name of this
performance that occurs the name of the
week we have a different name every time
cool the troupe is called Wizards light
Wizards light Wizards like that could be
Li gh T the light of inspiration or
Wizards Li T a little bit funny a little
bit you know non serious we the one we
did two years ago is called fire in the
sky because it turns out that everything
in our history has been started with a
fire in the sky the Sun the cosmos the
Sun then the volcanoes that pushed up
through the oceans that leave the
landscape to cycle those origin pools
and then you had these other fires that
were from the sky into the mine so you
had the asteroid impact that was a fire
God it pushed evolution yeah we wouldn't
be here and then the prosimians a little
two-inch ancestors of all apes and
monkeys their fire in the sky was the
dawn over the rain forests where they
were creeping out on the limb to try to
get tree sap and berries and they were
getting snap down by snakes yeah and
that's what gave us our visual cortex
that gave us our ability to see phones
and patterns it's 50 60 million years of
snake snapping or not snapping that's
why we are the way we are is because of
the the constant evolution was that was
snakes and serpents yeah yeah and then
that was snakes of serpents were from
the ocean creatures also had light or no
light yeah yeah light or no light yeah
and then when we discovered fire you
when Africa split in half and we had to
make fire to to cook meat to be able to
digest it because that was our food
source yeah and then of course the fire
the light of civilization you know that
came through and then Alamogordo the
fire of Trinity you know that we didn't
get consumed by that we didn't it
self-immolate and now the light has
turned on back the illest inian mystery
brought the illest in e'en potions of
LSD and mushrooms back into human
consciousness right up here in SF you
know in the 60s and it's it's now roll
through to re enlighten the human
intellect and the human healing of the
soul so that light turned on again and
then the turning on of the light of the
Internet of our cyber being that we've
fashioned that lights up every face you
know constantly yes you know and that's
a new form of a serpent that either can
coil around you and take all your prana
yeah but it also evolves us so the
serpent is back looking at us through
our smartphones yes maybe VR yes and
then we're being pushed and pushed and
pushed again so that's that's my story
tomorrow actually the toggle is story
yeah on stage tomorrow morning yes
oh these wizard lights we have so much
to explore because there's a lot to tell
there's a lot to story tell yeah yeah
and I I was in New Zealand recently
doing these hot spring experiments and I
flew down to Wellington as I was invited
by this fellow named Sir Richard Taylor
to go through wet a workshop so it's
where they made Lord of the Rings and
The Hobbit
they made 50 other films Blade Runner
for 20 49 and everything so it's the
world's greatest physical set
construction costumery studio mmm
so for three hours they gave me a tour
of how they made make everything then at
the end they handed me Gandalf sword so
I have it I can send you a picture of
this Glamdring yeah and the sword
masters on one side and Richard
tailors on the other side and he
declared me to be a young budding
Gandalf the gray so I've now taken that
role on and I'm actually now building
Gandalf house and my property here in
the Santa Cruz Mountains oh my god with
their help so we're going to Thailand to
get Thai artists to make copies there's
they've sent us thousands of pictures
from the Lord of the Rings and drawings
artists original renderings so we can
get the Gandalf house looking like
Kendall's house would be again I didn't
have a house but we all got together and
figured he deserved one and this is what
it would look like so this time next
year you can come you know come and we
can interview there on-site interview
yeah that's my wizards light you know
where the rest of my life will be in
there wizards light is is like the it's
the it's the synthesis of of life that
that delivers inspiration to the souls
of others that's a lot of what I aim to
do with the art creativity aiming to
manifest now um so that's really
exciting and I'm looking forward to our
other videos on the internet that we can
link in the in the bio of it there's
yeah damer comm will have the the two
TEDx talks for opening of space and the
origin of life and there's there's a lot
of stuff out there now because I've been
just touring for years now there's tons
of your talks
tons of my talks awesome links in the
bio damer calm and the levity zone
podcast which is my own personal diary
of this journey and levity zone org and
we that came one night in a conversation
with Terence Mckenna you probably know
from back in the day yeah
but Terence used to talk about novelty
all the time novelty curves and
singularities and stuff and one night I
said to him Terence we have enough
novelty we need more levity so that's
why our civilization needs to feel
better about itself and see itself in
more levity and more light more humor
yeah you know not be doom and gloom and
so that's what the the podcast is is
about yeah yeah
and so that levity and light and
inspiration can be creatively delivered
in so many ways and I find things like
the hundred billion that have lived and
died before us today to build this world
to be something I'm just extreme
passionate about you find the last four
billion years to be Gimli passion I do
too
and a proper synthesis of that to a
point today which increases the amount
of levity is so gorgeous okay here's the
other thing that I wanted to bring up
from what from where you were speaking
and I'm excited to hear what you have to
say about this the I have had I've had a
decent amount of contemplations around
the about about about evolution in about
natural selection and there it seems to
me from the more that I look at it the
more I realized that the proper
integration of of all of all humans into
humanity rather than dehumanization so
it's not I am intelligent therefore you
are inferior therefore I advanced and
you die that is old school
mmm-hmm that's old school the new school
is I I the new school is we are now
evolving with the evolution is now
evolving to select for altruism mm-hm
and the ones the ones that choose to be
most altruistic and assist in the in the
long term sustainable development of
society as every human is a different
color on the color wheel not a
significant
in de because it's so weird putting
things on like an IQ bell curve and then
saying like oh we're just all different
colors right because they're just those
things are so strange to say in the same
thing same phrase yeah there's a way of
seeing this yes so here's a simple way
of seeing this so here you have a field
of little entities that are competing
somewhat for resources generally for
most of the history of life on Earth
they're in a called a consortium that's
the model for microbial communities yes
the consortium model they kind of
compete but they also you know the top
layer distribute sunlight the products
of sunlight down to the lower layers and
they're in layers and so the community
evolves as a unit but then what happens
is a grid or a pressure comes slapping
down on that community and kills most of
it and that's the process of natural
selection a few members climb up through
and there's tough enough to survive the
new conditions whether it be more drying
higher ultraviolet radiation or
something or lack of resources and then
they they scrambled again and they
repopulate that on top of the grid and
then another grid comes slamming down
and then they climb again and then the
dream one night I was shown this and the
the entity and the dream said this is
how you were made and it is more like
lifting and gifting so you lift up the
polymeric the beautiful polymeric
products that'll allow you to survive
that that you are somehow given yeah
sometimes by random chance yeah
sometimes by consortium and then you
gift it to the next level that then
survive on the desert island yes and
then some other entity or other future
group is going to go that next step
climb that net and that next hill climb
that's actually the process that made us
and it seemed from a completely
different perspective
so individuals lift themselves into
their vest abilities and they give to
the next generation and that's how all
of human civilization successful
soldiers have been built because the
civilization invented brick-making or
maybe the the Chinese invented a whole
lot of Technology and then maybe China
fell because of Wars and plagues and
things and a little bit of that
invention came writing or paper making
came to Europe and then the Europeans
have been is something else that then
Europe then fell and this is this whole
thing and that's actually how we were
made and survival the fittest is nowhere
in there and I was told by the entity
this term survival of the fittest is
killing your civilization and killing
this world you must replace it because
this is the actual mechanism that made
you you've got the mechanism right but
the language is wrong and it's very
important to to change that out of which
is exactly what you were coming to in
rather than survival of the fittest it
is lifting and giving Jin gifting yeah
lifting and gifting new metaphor yeah
new metaphor yeah and so all of us in
our lives are doing that where we make
our children right we try to give to our
children the next yes the best tools and
we in the healing arts were relief tore
constantly a lift and gifting and then
where does the where does the where does
the word where are the parameters of
children for each individual because
some people think it's the earth some
people think it's their family yeah it's
the community where is it where is it I
think it's the whole thing so if you
raise a child that doesn't isn't the
front bite traumas or if a child
experiences a traumatic experience early
on there's extremely flexible plastic
they can go through healing quickly so
if we give them those tools like this is
Weis schoolyard bullying is ending thank
goodness because look at what it did
right but certain kinds of parenting
that are very demanding so the tiger
tiger parenting is extremely damaging to
children yeah right so it's called
bulldozer parenting now
well those are scary because they just
go through and bulldoze all the
obstacles for the child so that the
child has no no no obstacles in it's a
way of so we create we create a
different kind of human that way totally
so but we're at least now swell itself
aware that we're doing damage to the
next generation
perhaps them getting technology too soon
is changing their brain chemistry
because of all the dopamine so but we at
least are self aware of the risks that
we're running or as in past generations
it just sort of happened and nobody paid
any attention so society becoming
self-aware ah this could give us real
problems
interesting we're becoming more
self-aware of what we are building we
now have a better connected
communications infrastructure to have
more of those
yeah harder compensation and parents
like the the suicides in Palo Alto here
like a a dozen young people jumping onto
Cal train tracks from upper middle-class
privileged families because y know love
hard driving rigid kind of parenting
drove these young people to take their
lives and of course what did the
community do it built a fence and put a
security guard that's not a good
response but another part of the
community was like we have to own this
that we are destroying our young people
through this crazy mania of driving them
for performance and there's the love
they feel nothing and they don't know
they don't know that they're running a
deficit they just don't fall into dark
depression and they take their lives on
the railroad tracks in Palo Alto that's
a strong message that's already the top
0.1% on the planet yeah well look what
we were doing so we're making huge
mistakes but I think that you know
here's Transtech in the heart of Palo
Alto this kind of thing is happening
palette I thinked Alto people are smart
enough to say we've just made a huge
steak we must have a community meeting
and there will be a motion it would be
feeling and passion and we found out it
is actually unhealthy to drive young
person so hard but society told us well
they need to get through Stanford or Ivy
League and they need to be this way and
have five appointments a day and we
found out that's actually not right yeah
that we need to pull back from that so
before it would just be done and now
there's awareness of that and there's
open people feel safe enough to have
that conversation that's a big change
mm-hmm you know okay whoo
that's a heavy well that's a really
heavy we're sitting in the heart wolves
right here though what's going on with
with with the ROE Higgins as well is
heavy you know that's over a million
people move to Bangladesh yeah so that
that camp that that refugee camp isn't
quickly over became the largest in the
world
and just like that and you know here's
it's a big you know it's crazy because
the wood you know how does one determine
okay twelve people top point one percent
it's a certain color then there's the
million-plus move being displaced to
Bangladesh that's a significant amount
more people but they are not forty miles
away from us and mm-hmm
that's a different color so where do
resources go how do resources properly
get funneled down the hierarchy to those
yeah and I think the more that people
feel the pain like that they they don't
just gloss over and get the instant news
feed and they feel the pain of those
others the more human we're going to be
cut in that through the heart less like
Joe was saying if you feel it deeply in
your heart you can make it real that's a
big change for Entrepreneurship and for
any kind of
and the way I see it is I give this
metaphor all the time when people get
lose hope
say there's a hand that's moving up and
it's the visible hand of crazy news and
whatever you know it's the hand of sort
of in a way it's like Darth Vader
yeah but then there's the Jedi there's
like Luke moving up here and it's mostly
hidden and so the tools and what's being
done here and Transtech is part of this
hand and their Co evolving they're
pushing they push against each other so
this hand of craziness and darkness and
trauma needs to have that other one to
push against for it to rise and their Co
evolving and the Millennials I talked to
see both of them yeah
they see them clearly yeah and they jump
back and forth you know they had
childhoods where they saw trauma here
and they see powerful loving things here
yeah and they're like in the middle of
it they're riding it and it's just
pushing pushing pushing and it's just
evolution at work and so one of the
things master Yoda said in Star Wars
this is there may be a good place to end
was it he said something like Jedi knee
powerful Empire develop skills so the we
we need that we need something to work
against right so they're always magic
people powerful people powerful
technologists hartfeld people that
aren't filled people they need that
force to evolve and grow and as they
grow more and more powerful that force
grows powerful we need something to
evolve against and eventually it will
merge it will dissolve into one thing
and our trauma will be met and we will
be healed as a species and and we'll
make it and no matter what climate no
the plan is going to throw us we're
going to make it because we're we've
been through that mesh so many times and
we've lifted and we've kept gifting and
lifting and gifting gifting until we we
just make it we
we break out and we come into this union
you know it'll be like childhoods and
you know arthur c clarke and so it's
happening you know I just have complete
faith in that this is going where it
should because we're so rare that for
the cosmos like we're the one shot in
this little parsec here and so there's a
lot at stake there's a lot more in the
game then we can see then we can sense
yes the roots that reach down to hell
are able to sprout the leaves that reach
out to heaven that's that's great as
well needed oh yeah I like I like the
way you explain the lay in the dark and
it can definitely be destabilizing a lot
to bounce back and forth through the two
and they've got to have strong community
around you yeah to help ground and and
you know your self well because each of
us has those hands in side we all have
that so when we see it in society oh
yeah there's societal trauma
just like my trauma yeah and then you
have softened to it and you you open
with empathy societal trauma and face it
directly and it's societal trauma is our
trauma yeah yeah what are the forces at
play on earth that are hyper dimensional
I think us everything are they through
is it through us or are we are we not
are we is consciousness localized here
in this vehicle is there a soul that
comes through this vehicle what are your
thoughts about I think it's a huge
interconnected mesh that we can't see
but we can feel so we can't know it
intellectually but we can feel it and
operate with it uh-huh so for example
what I do when I come to a conference
like this is I kind of let myself be
taken over by that mm-hmm so I don't go
somewhere because I think it's a good
idea to go sit at that table I get moved
by this feel like my body's slow I'm
gonna slowing down stopping on standing
here and
and suddenly I'm standing next to this
person yeah who is incredibly important
to my mission to talk but I'm not
figuring it out I'm literally be I'm
like us like a string puppet yes in that
mode just being moved around because I'm
a faithful instrument of the field for
our survival that's that's how I've
lived my life yeah for our survival
because it's it's doing this chess move
like yeah okay you know for the monkeys
to yeah to get through we need to do
this and they're highly improbable
events being brought into actuality by
those the sheer magnitude of what this
probabilistic field is and you can test
it you can actually you can walk out the
door one day and say I'm just gonna be
in a negative state and I'm gonna be
thinking and worrying all day so watch
how it shakes your the feel right all
the people you work deal with at the
grocery store and when you're driving
and everything and then you go out the
next day it's like I'm gonna do breath
work I'm gonna get really clear I'm
gonna you know make love and I'm gonna
go out and I'm just gonna be in a state
of gratitude and warmth and love to
everyone I meet and watch how that
shapes the feel was like so different
you could just do scientific a be
testing on this thing yeah on your own
life yeah yeah that is a really easy
action item as long as people can stick
to it's a conscientiousness thing you
got to hold that contract with yourself
to to be negative or be upset or be all
these lower vibrational and feelings and
if they are there a part of you that was
hurt a long time ago yeah and then you
give that love that love yeah and it's
coming up it's like yeah I think there
is a lot more to unpack and
there's it's this is hopefully one of
many times that we sit down together I
want a quick dose into you kind of
brought it up a couple times but the
future of mmm yeah with you you you're
very optimistic and but realistic as
well about what what is going on and
even with the exponential technology
even with mm-hmm what we're seeing I
think it it it's all coming together
quite perfectly so you know if you look
back at the year 1990 on the verge of
the collapse of the super powers
potential thermonuclear war in 1970
crazy world just nobody knew where
anything was 1950 the world was half
devastated by World War two 1930 were
coming into a terrible depression 1910
were coming into the first trench like
first completely human machine war those
were not good time so I saw an image of
Pearl Harbor being bombed and I was just
like you know Peru Nagasaki not good
roles the 2010 2010 okay whoa
everyone's getting connected the nuclear
weapons have been set down from the time
we went through the nightmare of 9/11
and all that nonsense which was really a
holdover from you know a really
primitive way of thinking on both sides
2010 the smartphone arrives the world's
interconnected we have our local
challenges but 2010 was the first sort
of doe decadal year where according to
all measures it was 2010 to 2013 were
the peak of human health and
interconnectedness
I think 2013 was seen as like the
absolute humans had never had it so good
as far as health and opportunities
there was less violence because the
amount of global violence has been
dropping substantially and it's amazing
and so we're in this decade and we have
the craziness we have the trauma so we
have refugee camps as you pointed out
but we have something else we have this
powerful new connectedness that we've
never had as a species and the
understanding of the boot codes of
humans the most powerful tools we've
ever had for healing no from
psychedelics to all the the endogenous
tools and the ability to tell ourselves
our story we have everything we we need
to go forward we really do
there isn't one great existential
external nightmare Damocles sword
hanging over us like there has been for
the last hundred years there really has
been it's not there you know we can make
it up we can make a new one in our heads
and say oh that's our new Damocles sword
but it there is nothing like there was
in those decades is such a better world
right now yes
and there are still weaponry that can be
accessed even easier and even more
varied ways which it requires a lot of
civilization figuring out the worst
we're self aware you know anyone with a
smartphone can take a video of anything
and we know about it unfiltered that's
an amazingly powerful like yeah just
like instant great powers used to be
able to hold secrets and they can't
corporations can't hold secrets
everything is everything is an open-face
it's an amazing time it's never this has
never been before and stuff changes so
fast and rolls the system the financial
system rolls cryptocurrency you know
replacing Fiat and then crashes and then
new one comes in a new one and this the
serpent of civilization is undulating so
rapidly that no one can control it
there's no one driving he just throws
people off yeah and it is on a move
and so the meta beings of the
Millennials and people like yourself are
like yeah we know this this dynamic of
this continuous flow yeah we live in
this flow you know we're not we don't
have a tight grip on grippy old yeah
yeah yeah it's a very interesting time
to be alive on the planet and I wonder
if we used to say those same words every
time period before him we always you go
back to the year 1000 where they were
worried about the millennia of the you
know the was it we had the y2k they have
the white 1k problem that no one had a
stout standard calendar so nobody knew
when y1k was and in the 900s there was
this apocalyptic thing going on yeah it
seems to be especially in the the
European soul needs the apocalypse to
motivate it to go forward whereas in
South Asia you find that no it's a
regenerative cycling system it's very
cultural you know wow there's so much
more to unpack soon wizard's light and
we'll finish with another master yoda
yeah
so another master Yoda was Luke meets
his father who is Darth Vader Darth
Vader asked Luke take off this mask what
happened Luke sees the gentle pained
eyes of Darth and there is a healing of
the Empire yeah yeah it happened yeah
and that's
those forces yeah they did yeah
perfectly and then they did yeah
and that's one of the stories told by in
the Bay Area that's a great story we
tell humanity made right here in the Bay
Area you know everyone knows yeah Wow
you're so welcome
I'm grateful to be meet you then we'll
do this again thank you yeah thank you
thank you for everything that you're
doing and for everything that you're
teaching Thanks everything you're
bringing forward thank you everybody for
tuning in we would love for you to
comment below with your thoughts we'd
love to continue the conversation we
have a public telegram that you can join
and ask questions about the show also go
and build the future go and manifest
your dreams into the world go and
execute go and build go create much love
for you all thank you animals
[Music]
[Music]